toujours en france la mobilisation
annuelle de la marche pour la vie a eu
lieu à paris depuis 13 ans plusieurs
associations les pro vie comme alliant 8
ha où les associations familiales
catholiques saut et nice pour s'opposer
à l'avortement
une mobilisation de cette année d'autant
plus symbolique puisque le sénat étudie
la semaine prochaine deux textes au
coeur de leurs préoccupations
le projet de loi de bioéthique et
l'allongement du délai d'accès ali vg on
retrouve 1 place du trocadéro à paris
notre reporter david khalifa bonjour
david alors un rassemblement ont
maintenu malgré la situation sanitaire
quelles sont les conditions de la
manifestation
[Musique]
eh bien écoutez le rassemblement s'est
achevé sur les coups de 16h30 ici place
du trocadéro une forte mobilisation
malgré les restrictions sanitaires
puisque selon les organisateurs 3000
personnes étaient présentes ici place du
trocadéro avec un objectif clair pour
ces manifestants protester contre le
projet de loi bioéthique et
l'allongement du délai de l'image et de
douze à quatorze semaines de textes
examinés vous l'avez dit par le sénat
est cette semaine alors l'originalité
aussi de ce rassemblement à cet après
midi c'est qu'il était possible pour les
manifestants de suivre à distance ce
rassemblement via l application zoom une
première pour ce type de manifestation
l'avortement considéré comme un enjeu de
santé publique pour la plupart des
manifestants qui souhaitent la mise en
place d'une politique de prévention pour
réduire le recours à une ivg je vous
propose d'écouter quelques uns alors
c'était important pour moi d'être là
pour mettre pour envoyer un signal au
gouvernement pour qu'il mette enfin
entre guillemets qui met le un petit
stop sur les réformes qui viennent
menacer la famille que ce soit par la
conception de menacer la famille pardon
mais là c'est la vie et que ça soit sa
conception jusqu'à sa jusqu'à la fin de
sa vie à la fin de la ville avec les
potentiellement les lois de bioéthique
on espère vraiment que le gouvenement
qu'elle va faire marche arrière et que
avoir sur un compte que la vie est plus
importante que c'est un combat qui a
amené et que vraiment c'est peut-être
pas le moment
d'abord que c'est pas vraiment de
demeurer ces temps de changer la loi
parce qu'il ya d'autres préoccupations
et dans tous les cas je pense que la loi
n'est pas forcément très bonnes amies on
doit laisser la possibilité aux gens de
pouvoir choisir et l'allongement du
délai n'est vraiment pas une bonne chose
la défense de la vie c'est vraiment le
droit fondamental
on nous parle beaucoup des droits de
l'homme mais le premier droit c'est le
droit à la vie et ce droit ils se
discute pas il est absolu
si on commence à décider qui peut vivre
qui ne peut pas vivre
aucun droit ne peut tenir donc c'est
vraiment le fondement de toute la
civilisation et spécialement la
civilisation chrétienne
c'est vraiment là dessus qu'il faut se
battre selon les chiffres en 2019 on
recense près de 230 2201 ivg un record
dans l'hexagone à l'ehess qui souhaite
un des alternatives pour accompagner les
futures mères en difficulté et des aides
sociales plus nombreuses en tout cas ces
rassemblements encadrés par les forces
de l'ordre se dérouler dans le calme et
dans une ambiance festive et musicale
plusieurs concerts ont eu lieu un sur la
scène qui était monté ici et plusieurs
intervenants se sont succédés également
pour prévenir des dangers de
l'avortement sur la santé mentale des
femmes qui ont recours à l'évêché